لبنان هذا البلد الذي يعتبر على نطاق
الواسع بلدا ليبراليا بالمايير الاقليميه
حيث تلعب المراه دورا بارزا في الحياه
العامه هناك بحسب دراسه صادمه العادات
والتقاليد والعرف والعرض تشكل المجتمعات
حاجزا بالنسبه للسيدات في المجتمع
اللبنانيه دراسه لمنظمه ابعاد تقول ان
اكثر من نصف الاعتداءات الجنسيه في لبنان
تبقى طي الكتمان وعليه تصدر من تعرضت
للعنف الجنسي لكتمان الامر حتى لا تصبح
ثقلا على كاهل عائلتها وصمتها
ومن هنا وان صارت وكشفت الفتاه يحيط الخطر
بحياتها
نحن حاليا نبي اطار حمله 16 يوم لمناضل عن
فقام على نوع الاجتماعي واكيد في احصاءات
عملناها وبيست عليها اكيد ااا طلعنا
بمخرجات لهذه الحمله اذا بدكم هيك نحكي
اكثر احصاءات عن عن موضوع التحرش الجنسي
والاغتصاب همم الدراسه اللي عملناها
اعطتنا نتائج همم بين معنا ست من اصل 10
سيدات همم تعرضوا للاعتداء الجنسي بس همم
ما بلغوا عن هذا الاعتداء بسبب مبدا اساسي
اللي هو العرض والشرف همم والعار مثل ما
بينقال في عنا خمسه من اصل 10 نساء كمان
تعرضوا للاعتداء الجنسي بس كمان ما بلغوا
لانه عائلتهم رفضت التبليغ بسبب كمان
العارض همم والشرف اللي همم
باوتر التبليغ في عندنا ست من اصل كمان
عشر نساء اتعرضوا بناتهم لا داء الجلسه
وكانوا هن من الاشخاص اللي رفضوا كمان
يصير في تبليغ عن الاعتداء بسبب نفس
المبدا اللي هو العرض الشرف عندنا نحصر
الامور ونفهم اكثر بدقه عندما نتحدث عن
كلمه اعتداء جنسي يعني تحت اي كتغري يمكن
وضعها اولا يعني اتحدث عن التحرش نتحدث عن
اختصاب اعتداء تحرش لفظي ماذا بس نقول
تحقق اعتداء جنسي هو يشمل التحرش الجنسي
يشمل محاوله الاغتصاب او الاغتصاب هو اي
اي سلوك همم يتعدى المساحه الخاصه بالسيده
ومرتبطه
الاحتمالات او التصرفات الجنسيه طب ما دام
العداد كبيره
من الابلاغ عن هذه الحالات
للاسف للاسف نحنا بعدنا بيبي اه مثل بلدان
الشرق الاوسط اذا بدنا او دولنا العربيه
اللي بعدنا بنعمل وصمه على الناجي او على
ضحيه الاعتداء الجنسي ومنربط
الموضوع بالعار او او راح نعمل فضيحه باسم
العيله بكيانا العيله اي اعتداء جنسي هو
مرتبط بصار بالعيله كاين كلها مش بانه هي
حادثه فيها ذنب وفيه عقوبه عشان هيك
التبليغ راح يوصل السيد بمجتمعنا لانه
كثير هي موضع اتهام مش المعتدي